bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
troisième saison de sens public vous le
voyez dans un tout nouveau décor on est
très heureux et fier de l'inaugurer pour
toutes les émissions de la chaîne un
nouveau décor plus chaleureux plus
modulable plus ouvert sur le monde aussi
avec ses écrans XXL nouvelle écran donc
mais une promesse qui ne change pas et
d'ailleurs contenu vous le savez dans le
titre de l'émission sens publique donner
du sens à l'actualité se mettre au
service du public vous proposer des clés
de compréhension des crises que nous
traversons avec l'actualité politique
pour commencer une première année de
conflit et d'impasse pour Emmanuel
Macron dans la rue et au Parlement le
président veut donner un nouveau souffle
à son quinquennat il multiplie les
initiatives on va les analyser avec nos
experts on se penchera aussi sur la
rentrée du parti LR les républicains lui
aussi en quête d'espace politique ce
sera notre premier débat et puis dans
trois quarts d'heure on se posera cette
question sommes-nous condamnés à
l'effacement de la France en Afrique
après deux coups d'État successifs au
Niger et au Gabon qui rallonge la liste
des putschs qui ont frappé les pays
francophones depuis deux ans c'est la
question de notre second débat avec
c'est aussi l'actualité le nouveau
président de transition au Gabon qui
prêtait serment aujourd'hui Jésus
devant Dieu et le peuple gabonais
de préserver en toute fidélité le régime
républicain
de respecter et de faire respecter la
charte de la transition et la loi
un nouveau pouvoir au Gabon et au Niger
avec quelles conséquence pour les
intérêts français quelle place la Russie
et la Chine sont-elles en train de
prendre sur le continent africain et
puis aussi qui lutte aujourd'hui contre
les djihadistes réponses tout à l'heure
mais d'abord c'est deux mots
planification écologiques c'était une
promesse du candidat Macron pour sa
réélection un an après on devrait enfin
savoir si l'ambition sera à la hauteur
des enjeux Jonathan du priez
c'était une promesse de campagne du
candidat Macron en 2022 élaboré une
feuille de route pour la planification
écologique
pour plate de la planification
en charge du dossier Elisabeth borne a
précisé les objectifs chiffrés du plan
réduire de 50% les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre par rapport à 1990 et ce
d'ici à 2030 reste à détailler les
mesures concrètes à destination des
collectivités particuliers et
entreprises ce pourrait être le 18
septembre selon Le Parisien le ministre
en charge de la transition écologique
sans félicite dans les colonnes du
journal c'est une première aucun pays
n'a dit voilà les engagements que j'ai
pris et voilà comment je compte les
atteindre sauf que le doute s'est
installé sur les ambitions de l'exécutif
en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique le gouvernement
a reporté maintes fois ses annonces
d'abord percutées par les émeutes
urbaines et le remaniement ensuite et
lors des rencontres de Saint-Denis avec
les chefs de partis politiques Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas semblé se presser de
remettre le sujet sur la table
déçu on a discuté vous avez remarqué
très longtemps à peu près 12 heures je
pense et que à la sortie on a créé
apparemment beaucoup de groupes de
travail renvoyés à beaucoup de
réflexions ultérieure mais en 12 heures
il y a rien de nouveau sous le soleil ni
sur le plan social ni sur le plan
environnemental qu'on a quand même du
batailler pour remettre et remettre et
remettre sur la table sans que rien n'en
sorte en cette rentrée politique le flou
persiste sur la volonté réelle du
président de la République de mener à
bien les immenses chantiers liées au
climat le chef de l'État ayant choisi
d'accès son agenda sur l'éducation
nationale
les nombreuses initiatives politiques
d'Emmanuel Macron en cette rentrée le
parti LR la loi immigration les
questions autour d'un éventuel
référendum il y a beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder dans ce premier débat avec
Pascal Perino bonsoir bienvenue heureux
de vous accueillir sur ce nouveau
plateau vous qui est un habitué de sens
public comme mes deux autres invités je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue et
professeur à Sciences Po Paris
anne-charles bézina bienvenue à vous
bonsoir vous êtes constitutionnaliste
Mathieu souquier bienvenue et bonsoir
vous êtes essayiste coteur je cite
encore votre livre 2022 la flambée
populiste chez plomb et la Fondation
Jean Jaurès Mathieu croissandeau
bienvenue Mathieu et bonjour à tous vous
êtes éditorialiste politique allez on
commence il y a plein de thèmes donc on
va essayer de bien cadrer tout ça la
planification écologique parce que moi
j'avais un peu l'impression que c'est
l'arlésienne de ce de cette première
année du second quinquennat et vous oui
oui c'est un peu une arlésienne du
second quinquennat le premier
quinquennat pour une répliquer ça avant
d'ailleurs des quinquennat précédent
c'est quelque chose en effet qui fait
l'objet très souvent
d'affichage et en général quand on passe
aux mesures prises pour
appliquer cette planification
écologique de manière précise c'est là
où les où l'on est un peu déçu bien sûr
et puis c'est là que ça se complique
voilà ce qu'il faut faire des arbitrages
qui économiquement peuvent être
douloureux et c'est là économiquement ça
peut être douloureux socialement peut
être douloureux parce que souvenons-nous
du mouvement des gilets jaunes qui
naient au fond d'une réaction de couches
sociales qui ne supporte pas j'allais
dire la mise en action de la
planification écologique donc c'est une
heure des choix qui est très difficile
surtout à l'heure on s'interroge
beaucoup je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué dans le débat aujourd'hui sur
le lien des politiques aux différents
milieux sociaux les couches populaires
les couches moyennes etc alors autant
c'est un discours je crois qui parle
assez directement au coucher moyenne et
en particulier au couche moyenne
supérieur en revanche dans les couches
populaires quand il s'agit de choisir et
bien ce sont les arguments économiques
et sociaux très souvent qui l'emportent
sur les arguments purement écologiques
même si les couches populaires ont une
sensibilité bien sûr écologique mais
quand ça tape au porte-monnaie c'est une
autre affaire qui qui est en complique
évidemment la donne politique Mathieu
souker
le ministre Christophe Béchu nous
annonce alors on verra si c'est suivi
l'effet un d'ici 15 jours une
planification vraiment ambitieuse
est-ce que vraiment Emmanuel Macron peut
faire de la France parce que c'est ce
qu'il affiche Christophe Béchu le pays
le plus avancé d'Europe en matière de
transformation environnementale ce qui
est sûr c'est que Emmanuel Macron n'est
pas de nos présidents de la République
ou de nos gouvernants celui qui affiche
un habituus je mets des guillemets au
terme mais un habitude écolo le plus
affirmé qui soit on se souvient qu'il y
a quelques temps encore dénoncer le
modèle à niche etc donc on s'attend on
s'attendait pas à ce que Emmanuel Macron
devienne effectivement le candidat et le
président de l'écologie sous son second
mandat il y a le contexte il y a eu le
contexte politique de la présidentielle
qui a fait que pour rallier les voix des
électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a dû
mettre la planification écologique au
cœur de son programme et puis il y a le
contexte plus global qui fait que quand
même en fait les la crise climatique
nous ont percevons quotidiennement très
concrètement de plus en plus les effets
et donc à chaque rentrée après des étés
caniculaires après des incendies de plus
en plus forts de plus en plus intense on
voit bien que le contexte bouge et
j'entendais ce que disait Pascal
Perrineau effectivement toutes les
catégories sociales toutes les classes
d'âge n'appréhendent pas le phénomène de
la même façon il n'empêche que depuis
quelques mois vous aurez noté que la
menace climatique constitue un des deux
ressorts principaux du mal-être français
et puis l'installation il y a la
question sociale mais il y a désormais
aussi la question environnement mais si
on va plus loin malgré le consensus
scientifique il est il est partagé
partout sur la planète il y a encore 8%
des Français selon les derniers sondages
qui qui ne croient pas au réchauffement
et 25 ou 27% qui disent que c'est palier
à l'activité humaine donc il y a est-ce
que est-ce que ça peut être un frein à
l'ambition d'un politique et là je vais
au-delà du cas d'Emmanuel Macron faut
chiffres que vous évoquez que je ne
conteste pas j'opposerai ceux qui disent
quand même que désormais une majorité de
Français considère que il faut aller
plus vite et que le gouvernement ne va
pas assez vite et je note que dans la
société civile un certain nombre de
mouvements alors activistes radicaux ou
même sans penser aux activistes radicaux
on attaque aujourd'hui le gouvernement
français pour inaction climatique et on
parvient à le faire condamner et dernier
élément là-dessus c'est quand même
effectivement la première fois que on se
dote au niveau gouvernemental d'un outil
technocratique administratif comme
celui-ci c'est quoi en fait le
secrétariat de le secrétariat général à
la planification écologique c'est une
vingtaine ou une trentaine de techno
ultra compétents sur le sujet qui ont
vocation à construire les tableaux de
bord de la transition environnementale
alors encore une fois il y aura
peut-être quelque chose de technique et
en chambre mais au on se donne d'outils
qui sont relativement inédits alors on a
vu dans le sujet d'ouverture le prénom
de la République il aurait pu mettre ce
thème sur la table de de ces discussions
marathon avec les chefs de partir la
semaine dernière à Saint-Denis vous en
pensez quoi ça ne se nouveau rendez-vous
institution institutionnel je sais pas
si on peut appeler ça un rendez-vous
institutionnel ou en tout cas de cette
initiative politique du président alors
la première chose à dire c'est qu'en
effet elle est tout à fait para
constitutionnelle par habituel sous la
Cinquième République c'est tout à fait
nouveau qu'est-ce qui est nouveau c'est
finalement l'absence de cadre et aussi
l'idée que l'opposition ne joue pas un
rôle d'opposition dans ces moments là
c'est à dire qu'on essaye de devenir
complètement on est dans une discussion
qui se veut être des passionnée par
rapport à ce qu'on a pu voir d'une
Assemblée nationale un peu violente
pendant les débats de la réforme des
retraites il y a aussi autre chose c'est
que c'est le président de la République
qui s'en charge donc un président qui
prend un petit peu la place de son
premier ministre puisque c'est plutôt
une rentrée parlementaire au sein des
assemblées qui se passent
généralement dans ces mois de septembre
et on voit bien qu'on a ici un peu les
paradoxes de Jupiter c'est à dire un
président qui à la fois une décidait
seul et qui pourtant consulte beaucoup à
beaucoup aussi d'habitude de discours
plus
performative avec cette idée de toujours
convaincre alors sur la planification
écologique l'idée que ce soit la grande
absente de ces discussions c'est
peut-être aussi parce que aussi bien le
mot planification que écologie sont
remplies en fait de plein de sens de
paradoxe la planification en droit c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas censé
complètement vous lier puisque sont
généralement des objectifs plus ryannels
qui sont donnés et on a toujours eu un
petit peu de mal à faire de la
planification un programme de
gouvernement en matière écologique
est-ce que c'est de l'écologie politique
est-ce que c'est de l'écologie
purement
de coloration on va dire du discours
politique est-ce qu'il y a pas de
mesures derrière il y a beaucoup de
choses en fait qui auraient pu être
arbitré lors de ce moment-là donc l'idée
qu'on en est pas parlé c'est peut-être
aussi parce qu'on n'est pas complètement
sûr de ce qu'il y a derrière cette
planification écologique d'où l'idée
aussi que la première ministre qui est
la première ministre à tirer avec cette
idée d'être première ministre la
transition écologique et bien n'est
toujours pas incarnée cette idée de la
transition ni la matérialité en fait de
ce qu'est ce programme politique il y a
un mot ensuite on va parler de la
rentrée des DLR mais Pascal Paris un mot
quand même de ces rencontres de
Saint-Denis alors nous on n'était pas
l'antenne la semaine dernière donc on
résiste quand même à l'envie de faire
tous les thèmes qu'on a pas traité cet
été il y en avait plein mais ça c'est
quand même comment c'est quoi c'est de
la gomme purée simple c'est trop tôt
peut-être pour le dire on attend de voir
s'il y aura d'autres rendez-vous du même
du même type d'insulter l'avenir donc
c'est plutôt pour le dire voilà si ça
n'est que de la comme c'est assez
dangereux
si c'est autre chose que de la colle
c'est habile c'est habile parce que on
avait un président qui était en
difficulté face au mouvement de
contestation
d'usure sur l'enjeu des retraites qui
avaient un problème pour se remettre
j'allais dire au premier plan de
l'actualité et qu'il a une fois de plus
à innover ce qui est assez surprenant
avec ce Président c'est qu'il innove il
est toujours comme vous le disiez à côté
des institutions il tente de faire vivre
cette démocratie
participative à côté de la démocratie
représentative et au fond cette
rencontre de Saint-Denis c'est dans
cette lignée là qu'il faut la comprendre
et tout de même c'est une réussite en
tout cas dans un premier temps parce que
tout le monde y est allé personne n'a
claqué la porte ne serait-ce que pour
ces deux raisons c'est assez bien joué
et le fait que le président du
Rassemblement national soit présent
Matthieu souquier est-ce que c'est un
grand supplémentaire finalement dans la
normalisation de ce parti alors c'est
sûr qu'en plus il y a eu quand même un
mini flottement avant que la réunion se
tienne puisque on était pas sûr de
savoir qui allait y participer on savait
plus très bien qui participait ou pas à
l'arc républicain alors oui c'est sûr
qu'il y a un effet normalisation
supplémentaire s'agissant d'extrême
droite c'est incontestable en plus dans
les petits commentaires qui ont été
faits de la Réunion on a expliqué que
Jordan mardella avait été un de ceux qui
avaient le mieux préparé la Réunion
c'est incontestable pour rebondir sur ce
que disait Pascal Perrineau
effectivement tout le monde est venu
tout le monde est resté personne n'a
claqué la porte et je dirais même que
alors que les représentants de la
nupesse avaient dit qu'ils ne
participerait pas au dîner ils sont fait
coincer puisque on sait que la Réunion
c'est éternisé
globalement manifestement sur les sujets
de politique internationale quand même
il y a une sorte de consensus ou en tout
cas ce sont les éléments de langage que
l'Élysée a utilisé derrière en disant
sur l'international ça peut être
contestation en fait de la ligne de la
France c'est déjà pas rien et je dirais
qu'il y a un cran supplémentaire c'est
que on sait pas ce que ça va donner mais
Emmanuel Macron manifestement à proposer
que cette initiative se renouvelle et
les uns et les autres ont dit il est
possible qu'on revienne en tout cas
personne n'a dit c'était durant c'était
de la com pas question de s'associer à
ça et dernière dimension effectivement
non seulement ça lui permet en innovant
de se remettre un peu au centre du jeu
et même d'être un peu en avance de phase
alors que depuis un an il était
cornérisé et plutôt en retard c'est pas
rien et la seule chose un tout petit peu
concrète qui ressemble de cette
conférence pas grand chose au bout de 12
heures mais quand même un mini truc
c'est la conférence sociale on attendait
quand même Emmanuel Macron plutôt s'il y
avait une proposition concrète d'être
sur quelque chose qui puisse être Dilé
avec les républicains avec la droite en
tout cas on rentrait quand même dans la
réunion avec ça alors à la fin la gauche
se fait un peu coincer parce que c'est
finalement la conférence sociale qui
sort du chapeau alors justement la
droite on va en parler tout de suite
avec vous Mathieu puisque on a décidé
ensemble de se pencher sur le la rentrée
du parti LR comment les républicains
abordent-ils ce mois de septembre en
2001 côté pile le parti a plutôt réussi
à penser ses plaies enfin disons que les
divisions affichées au grand jour au
moment de la réforme des retraites sont
derrière
pour l'instant j'ai envie de dire on
verra si ça recraque et le parti les
républicains a fait sa rentrée au Cannet
sous le signe d'une relative unité la
plupart des ténor était là ils ont
chanté du Sardou
je suis pas sûr qu'ils avaient lu les
paroles parce que quand on voit terre
brûlée des Landes de pierre du Connemara
ça fait pas très champêtre et si vous y
ajoutez des nuages qui viennent du nord
colorent la terre des nuages noirs ça
sent au minimum l'orage enfin je
plaisante mais pour l'instant pas de
coup de tonnerre ni d'éclair c'est même
plutôt le calme plat comme le disait
Gérard Larcher le président du Sénat
hier sur France Inter il faut d'abord
rebâtir un projet retrouver la confiance
avec les Français et puis le moment venu
il y aura choisi un candidat autant dire
que tout reste à faire c'est compliqué
ouais c'est pas gagné parce que pour ce
qui est du projet d'abord parce que
l'espace politique des républicains mais
se réduit comme peau de chagrin en cette
rentrée en choisissant de de d'incarner
de décliner l'axe des priorités sur le
régalien l'exécutif lui prend de
l'oxygène en venant une politique de
droite on fait mal à la droite ça c'est
classique avec des symboles forts comme
interdiction de la Baïa par exemple et
puis encore Marine Le Pen n'a pas encore
fait sa rentrée donc quand elle viendra
la poutre continuera à travailler pour
reprendre la formule de d'Édouard
Philippe quand pour ce qui est du futur
candidat parce que j'avais l'argent
c'est évidemment beaucoup trop tôt sauf
que en face les manœuvres on commençait
et que du coup il y a des secousses
sismiques qui font bouger un petit peu
les plaques à l'éruption quand même d'un
Gérald Darmanin qui se revendique de
l'héritage gaulliste pour parler aux
classes populaires mais forcément la
droite de se positionner il y a la
popularité d'Édouard Philippe qui se
maintient tout ça soit prise d'oxygène
le candidat naturel Laurent Wauquiez qui
lui reste perché à 1753 mètres
d'altitude sur son mont Mézenc en fait
le patron de la région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes joue la stratégie du silence
pour se faire désirer le problème c'est
pour l'instant il ne parvient jusqu'à se
faire oublier et un sondage paru dans le
Parisien hier qui montrait qu'il était
relégué très plus loin très loin
derrière les concurrents de majorité et
d'ailleurs on va le commenter en détail
ce sondage tout à l'heure est-ce que les
LR peuvent se relancer et si oui comment
oui alors il y a trois enjeux pour eux
en cette rentrée il y a les sanatoriales
d'abord qui devrait a priori leur
bénéficier et leur permettre de
conserver ce village gaulois au Palais
du Luxembourg ou ils peuvent en tout cas
peser sur les choix de la majorité il y
a un autre texte un texte sur le coup
c'est la loi immigration qui qui se
profile qui pourra pas se faire sans eux
et pour laquelle ils entendent bien pour
le coup profiter de leur position de
force avant même que les négociations en
bonne et du forme ont commencé on sent
même que la majorité est déjà prête à
lâcher du lest notamment vous savez sur
l'aspect régularisation des travailleurs
sans papiers dans les secteurs en
tension et puis enfin troisième élément
qui pourrait jouer en leur faveur ou pas
c'est le vote des lois de finances qui
va servir au fond d'heures de vérité et
Elisabeth borne a déjà annoncé des 49-3
en cascade on sait qu'il en faut une
bonne dizaine pour faire valider là les
projets boss finances et les projets de
financement la sécurité sociale ça va
être autant d'occasions pour les
républicains de voir s'ils sont capables
de déposer une mention de censure parce
qu'on sait que eux seuls peuvent
rassembler autour d'une motion de
censure à l'Assemblée pour faire chuter
évidemment le gouvernement alors
certains chez les républicains ont déjà
le doigt sur la gâchette mais
oseront-ils seulement tiré effectivement
un Charline ou je rebondis sur cette
dernière question de de Mathieu motion
de censure elle a l'air à l'occasion de
d'idée des lois de finances est-ce que
vous y croyez que quels sont les quels
seraient les conséquences il y a
toujours un effet domino dans ce cas-là
une conséquence directe qui est la le
fait de démettre le gouvernement en
place alors avec le risque aussi que la
seule motion de censure il y a aboutie
sous la Cinquième République étant celle
de 62 que le président renomme le même
Premier ministre affronte avait fait le
général de Gaulle à l'Assemblée
nationale en renommant Georges Pompidou
on peut dire que la configuration
politique actuelle ne conduirait
sûrement pas le président Macron à faire
cela mais le risque de la motion de
censure c'est d'être dans une possible
de jusqu'au-boutisme c'est-à-dire le
renversement plus que la discussion la
négociation etc on s'est rendu avec la
réforme des retraites d'ailleurs que
c'était le chant lexical qui avait
choisi le gouvernement en proposant le
dialogue et en cornérison un petit peu
les oppositions en disant mais vous
voyez que vous n'avez pas su faire autre
chose que de proposer le chaos etc et
c'est vrai que la motion de censure
telle qu'elle est existe en France n'est
pas une motion de censure allemande vous
devez prononcer et proposer un nouveau
gouvernement vous ne faites que des
maîtres donc c'est pas forcément une
attitude qui va dans le sens de redorer
le parti les républicains en tout cas
partie des républicains qui se
voudraient défenseurs d'un projet
cohérent parce que être dans la
démission de ce gouvernement c'est aussi
savoir proposer autre chose et là on se
demande un petit peu quel sera le fameux
programme alors néanmoins les lois de
finances il faut pas oublier que c'est
vraiment le moment où on compte les
siens donc peut-être que le groupe les
républicains a ici un enjeu d'identité à
jouer est-ce qu'il compose la majorité
élargie ou est-ce qu'au contraire il est
véritablement dans l'opposition il faut
savoir que l'année dernière les LR
étaient plutôt au contraire dans les
textes financiers alliés de la majorité
et que leur discours est un discours
d'austérité donc le texte budgétaire est
pas tellement un endroit un moment de la
vie parlementaire que les LR ont envie
d'afficher comme étant un moment où ils
vont s'opposer Mathieu qui a plus de
risques potentiels pour les LR que
davantage à développer une à déposer une
éventuelle motion de censure leur
fragilité ne vient pas de nulle part en
réalité les hésitations ne viennent pas
de nulle part la droite est aujourd'hui
à peu près dans la même situation que la
gauche qui a 5 ans un an après la
première élection d'Emmanuel Macron elle
s'est fait siphonner l'année dernière à
l'occasion de la présidentielle
totalement siphonné sur le plan des
idées on voit bien aussi que le contexte
ne lui est plus favorable en 2012 par
exemple le désendettement public était
une des premières préoccupations des
Français aujourd'hui on parle plus du
tout de dette pendant très longtemps le
programme de la droite c'était moins
d'impôts moins d'État on a redécouvert
l'interventionnisme public est-ce que
demande aujourd'hui l'opinion
globalement c'est qu'on restaure un
grand service public auquel on est très
attaché et qu'on a laissé s'abîmer donc
l'hôpital donc l'école donc la police
donc la justice et ça la droite on a la
voir quel est un discours là dessus et
même la planification écologique ou la
transition environnementale on voit que
de tous les grands partis et même encore
plus que l'extrême droite elle est loin
du ballon là-dessus donc elle a un vrai
problème sur le fond en termes de
positionnement et puis il y a
effectivement ce que vous disiez c'est à
dire que la droite en réalité elle est
au pouvoir elle est au pouvoir elle est
au pouvoir et les espoirs politiques
demain quant à l'héritage de la du
macronisme ce sont Bruno Le Maire ce
sont Édouard Philippe ce sont si on y
reviendra avec le sondage tout à l'heure
actuelle juste une chose sur la motion
de censure Emmanuel Macron avait prévenu
à l'automne dernier en 2022 si émotion
de censure est adoptée il y aura 10
solutions donc c'est pour ça que des
risques politiques et voilà il y a aussi
ça qui rentre en ligne de compte parce
qu'au-delà de la mauvaise image que ça
pourrait donner ou des contradictions
qui pourraient pas être au grand jour en
faisant chuter le gouvernement sur un
sur un texte financier ou budgétaire et
surtout le risque de repasser dans les
yeux on est là est-ce que les électeurs
se tourneraient font reste difficile à
justifier comme au moment de la réforme
des retraites alors comment s'opposer à
une réforme qu'on avait globalement
apporter au moment de l'élection
présidentielle alors vous citiez tout à
l'heure Mathieu le préventionnel Gérard
Larcher dans son interview sur sur
France Inter hier il faut d'abord
rebâtir un projet parce que le périno
quand j'entends ça bon ça fait quand
même un an qu'il y a eu le fiasco de la
présidentielle est-ce que le à quel
point le parti a travaillé sur les idées
ou pas d'ailleurs pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup et en plus ça ils ne sont pas
d'accord on l'a bien on l'a bien vu au
moment de la réforme de l'âge de la
retraite ils ne sont pas d'accord et
c'est pas le seul sujet sur lequel il
n'y a pas d'accord donc ça montre
l'ampleur de la reconstruction d'un
projet mais surtout sur cette affaire
d'une éventuelle mise en cause la
responsabilité du gouvernement LR s'il
allait jusque là j'aurais très gros
pourquoi parce que LR c'est l'image
d'une droite de gouvernement qu'est-ce
qu'il y a aujourd'hui il y a une droite
de protestation très claire avec le
rassemblement national il y a une droite
au pouvoir horizon toute une partie de
renaissance etc voilà ils sont au
pouvoir eux il faut qu'il joue j'allais
un troisième option c'est la droite de
gouvernement qui pourrait se présenter
comme une alternative et pour cela en
effet il faudrait un projet à des fautes
de programme au moins quelques axes sur
lequel se partie extrêmement divers en
fait arriverait à se mettre d'accord il
faudra un homme et on voit qu'il n'y a
pas d'homme pour l'instant il y en a
plusieurs et c'est tout même un parti
dans lequel le culte du chef est
important faudra bien un moment que les
républicains se mettent d'accord sur le
chef qui doit chauffer comme disait
comme disait Jacques Chirac et puis il
faut un mode d'organisation on voit bien
que au fond le parti assez traditionnel
qui est resté les républicains n'est
plus tout à fait adapté aux enjeux de
leur donc ça fait beaucoup de chantier
en même temps 3 oui alors je vous ai
interrompu tout à l'heure Mathieu Souka
comme vous disiez que les Français
comment ont plutôt chercher en dehors du
parti LR des chefs naturels on va dire
ça comme ça de de la droite et du centre
effectivement c'est le sens du du
sondage publié par nos confrères du
Parisien sondage Opinionway pour le
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France dévoilé
ce week-end alors on a choisi deux
plusieurs questions mais ces
personnalités seraient la même de
rassembler la droite et le Centre pour
la présidentielle d'abord question poser
à l'ensemble des Français on a Edouard
Philippe qui arrive largement en tête à
42% et ensuite effectivement deux
ministres d'Emmanuel Macron Bruno Le
Maire à 27 Gérald Darmanin à 22 vienne
ensuite Xavier Bertrand puis seulement
Laurent Wauquiez et alors si on regarde
les résultats auprès des sympathisants
de droite alors on va peut-être les voir
s'afficher on a un lueur Philippe qui
est évidemment plus haut mais qui a qui
maintient un écart 66% droite et du
centre Xavier Bertrand 54% Bruno Lemerc
53 Laurent Wauquiez 50% et Gérald
Darmanin seulement à
44%. quelle leçon vous tirez vous poser
un peu la même question aux uns et aux
autres de ce sondage comment ça Mathieu
souker il y a une génération de leaders
de droite qui a disparu on l'avait pas
vu venir mais les filles ont les Sarkozy
les Juppé etc sont sortis du jeu la
relève n'avait pas été préparée ou plus
exactement une partie de la relève se
trouve aux affaires on pourrait ajouter
Jean Castex ils sont là en réalité et
ils appliquent une politique de droite
les deux autres qu'on voit Valérie
Pécresse et et Xavier Bertrand on fait
de manifestes contre-performance à la
primaire de leur partie ou à l'élection
présidentielle donc la question de la
relève elle est posée celui évidemment
dont on cause beaucoup c'est Laurent
Wauquiez c'est Laurent Wauquiez parce
que il est le seul à être resté
effectivement chez les républicains et
très prudemment ils ne s'affiche plus en
lité depuis qu'il aurait vocation à le
faire il a pas pris le parti il a pas
cherché à prendre le parti et il ne
prend position sur aucun sujet y compris
pas la réforme des retraites voilà à ce
stade on ne peut pas dire que ça paye il
y a une autre dimension quand même qui
est celle effectivement que ce soit
Laurent Wauquiez ou quelqu'un d'autre
qu'il incarne de savoir ce qu'on incarne
et là pour le coup je le fais référence
à celui qui fut le leader incontesté de
la droite pendant très longtemps Nicolas
Sarkozy qui est sorti du bois avec son
livre ces derniers temps et j'ai été
assez frappé par la quasi-totalité des
déclarations qu'il a faites sur
l'Ukraine évidemment et sur la Russie où
on l'a beaucoup critiqué sur le JDD qui
est un journal de centre droit et ça ne
pose pas de problème mais plus encore je
dirais sur la nécessité qu'il a exprimé
en fait de trouver quelqu'un qui à
droite permet de faire la synthèse la
synthèse entre Emmanuel Macron
LR et Éric Zemmour et la façon dont
Nicolas Sarkozy lui-même a posé cette
équation me paraît quand même
extrêmement questionnante comment
imaginer que le prochain leader de la
droite soit celui qui soit amené à faire
la synthèse d'Emmanuel Macron jusqu'à
Éric Zemmour dont on a quand même
compris qu'ils incarnaient deux projets
politiques radicalement différents
radicalement différent donc que le
leader de la droite que l'on veut dire
que le droit de zemmourice elle est deux
elle est forcément ancrée à l'extrême
droite j'ai le sentiment qui a une très
grande confusion voire même un
délitement auquel Nicolas Sarkozy me
semble lui-même en réalité contribué
quand on dit quelque chose comme ça je
derrière quand même il me semble qu'il y
a une très grande confusion et ça pose
la question non seulement de
l'Incarnation mais de la ligne politique
que ce soit Laurent Wauquiez ou un autre
la question qui sera posée à la droite
dans quelques années c'est de savoir
s'il y a une alliance au centre avec les
héritiers du macronisme ou s'il y a une
union à droite avec ceux qui se
revendiquent du rassemblement national
ou de reconquêtement ça c'est une vraie
question qui reste ouverte à une
certaine on parle Laurent Wauquiez
est-ce que ce sondage peut l'inciter à
parler plus d'une certaine façon c'est
une grande question parce qu'on constate
en réalité que les candidats s'adaptent
désormais à un nouveau temps politique
qui est très intéressant à analyser et
qui consiste à nous sortir qu'au dernier
moment sous peine d'avoir à 4 ans de la
présidentielle et on est déjà en train
de commenter mais rappelez-vous les
temps anciens c'est le second mandat qui
veut ça aussi
j'en Chirac François Mitterrand qui
était en campagne permanente qui était
vraiment tout le temps audible entendu
etc aujourd'hui on a le sentiment que
finalement tout se joue à la dernière
minute alors ça n'est pas faux l'opinion
est très volatile surtout en France et
maintenant voilà les campagnes
s'adaptent à ces nouveaux mouvements de
l'opinion c'est-à-dire on ne sort qu'au
dernier moment on l'a vu avec la
candidature d'Éric Zemmour lors de la
dernière présidentielle est-ce que pour
autant la stratégie est payante
objectivement non et en plus la question
pour le dire alors là on juge la
stratégie de Laurent Wauquiez c'est
encore une fois c'est dans quatre ans je
pense qu'il y a encore une nuance entre
être candidat et occuper l'espace public
parce que la vraie question c'est
finalement on a parlé de d'une
génération qui s'est éteinte mais on ne
parle pas d'héritage de qui va se
réclamer le nouveau leader DLR et de
quelle frange finalement va-t-il émaner
parce qu'on voit bien ici qu'on a
plusieurs noms qui finalement
correspondent à des projets tout à fait
différents à chaque fois donc si Laurent
Wauquiez veut vraiment rassembler ou au
contraire peut-être qu'il y avait ou
trouver un champ il serait temps
peut-être qu'il marque son identité
qu'on le sache de qui il se réclame et
où il veut aller et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui cette idée pas forcément
être candidat peut payer mais l'idée de
disparaître complètement des radars me
semble un petit peu dangereuses
qui pensent que l'élection doit leur
revenir perdre une élection ça cherchait
avec les dents comme disait l'autre
comme la croissance autrefois et donc
oui certains se déclarent au dernier
moment mais en gros vous prenez les
trois arrivées en tête lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle c'est
des gens dont ils n'étaient pas mystère
et qu'ils étaient candidats que ce soit
Marine Le Pen que ce soit Emmanuel
Macron pour sa succession et ce soit
Jean-Luc Mélenchon elle élection d'avant
même topo l'idée d'attendre au dernier
moment en disant je serai mieux placé et
on viendra me chercher ça ne marche pas
c'est d'ailleurs à mon avis un des
dangers qui guettent Édouard Philippe
aussi parce que au delà d'occuper
l'espace médiatique il faut raconter il
faut proposer et on peut pas arriver
comme ça au dernier moment un retour
atmosphère où on dit ah ben tiens au
fait j'ai trois quatre idées même ses
amis le pouce ont ok à réagir parce que
ce qu'a fait Gérald Darmanin à la
rentrée en essayant de se revendiquer du
gaullisme pour parler aux classes
populaires et notamment ce refrain
prenons date mais ça bouge tout le monde
ça bouge au sein de la majorité ses
concurrents directs mais ça bouge aussi
à droite ils vont être obligés à un
moment de se dire mais voilà nous aussi
on a des choses à raconter or pour
l'instant on ne les entend plus comme
s'il n'avait rien à dire oui parce
qu'effectivement il y a il y a une
ambition affichée par géraldman mais
aussi une positionnement politique on
peut dire ça comme ça là la question
c'est qui incarne quel courant de cette
droite de gouvernement c'est ça le
problème essentiel c'est la notion de
courant parce que là on joue en effet il
faut le faire avec des individus plus ou
moins présents dans l'espace médiatique
mais de quoi sont-ils l'expression de
quoi sont-ils le nom or il y a sur la
longue période si vous voulez des des
grands courants de la droite la droite
n'est pas une unité la droite est
pluriel on l'a on l'a toujours constaté
depuis de très longues décennies et il y
a une droite réactionnaire qui a
toujours existé au fond que Éric Zemmour
représente assez bien dans les
thématiques qu'il avance il y a une
droite plus de j'allais dire des régions
à droite plus nota biliaires ce qu'on
qualifié jadis de droite orléansiste
que telle ou telle candidat peut
prétendre représenter Giscard d'Estaing
l'avait bien incarné d'une certaine
manière et puis il y a une droite qui a
la tripe plus nationale et populaire que
le général de Gaulle représentait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui Gérald Darmanin
tente d'occuper et au fond quand on se
pose le problème moi ce qui me frappe
toujours c'est que les républicains ont
des candidats quand on regarde cette
enquête qui ne sont pas en général aux
parties les républicains ça pose un
léger problème
ça pose vraiment à un gros problème et
pour celui qui est véritablement
républicain Laurent Wauquiez à quel
droit appartient-il ou serait bien en
peine de l'affecter par exemple un des
trois courants que je viens de
mentionner alors on va continuer de de
parler à la fois d'Emmanuel Macron et de
la droite en s'intéressant maintenant et
ça va être la chronique de Steve
Jourdain à l'un des leviers
institutionnels pour le alors là dans le
nouveau décor je me lève l'événement
dingue voilà je me lève je sais quelque
part et si le Jourdain me rejoint
bonsoir mais merci c'est chez vous c'est
chez nous évidemment et un grand merci
tient d'ailleurs à toutes les équipes de
publics enfin un boulot de dingue pour
voilà pour nous offrir ce nouveau décor
en cette rentrée bravo bravo à toutes et
à tous alors le référendum c'est quoi
l'une des stars de cette rentrée
politique ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il
a fait une rentrée en fanfare un C
Emmanuel Macron lui-même qui a allumé le
feu c'était fin août le chef de l'État
accordé une interview à nos confrères du
soin on élit la chose suivante Thomas je
pense compte tenu de moments que nous
vivons qu'une initiative politique est
indispensable référendum fait toujours
partie des options qui peuvent être
utilisées je compte bien y avoir recours
depuis cette interview Emmanuel Macron
vous en parliez tout à l'heure à réuni
les chefs de parti c'était à Saint-Denis
c'était la semaine dernière alors là on
s'est rendu compte que tout le monde
voulait son référendum la gauche veut un
référendum sur les retraites la droite
et l'extrême droite sur l'immigration
pour le moment aucun engagement n'a été
pris du côté d'Emmanuel Macron ce qui
est acté c'est une nouvelle invitation
en direction des oppositions sur un
format identique à celui organisé à
Saint-Nicolas alors est-ce que c'est
légalement possible d'organiser de
telles référendum alors je parle sur le
contrôle de nos invités
actuellement par la Constitution pour
organiser un référendum il faut se
reporter à l'article 11 et l'article 89
l'article 11 prévoit une consultation
des français portant sur l'organisation
des pouvoirs publics ou sur les sujets
économiques et sociaux mais tout ce qui
concerne le droit civil ou le droit
pénal ne pue pas figurer dans un tel
scrutin la Constitution l'interdit
l'article 89 permet quant à lui et bien
de modifier cette Constitution à
condition qu'un texte soit adopté dans
les mêmes termes par les deux assemblées
et que ce texte soit ensuite validé par
les Français alors si je résume si
Emmanuel Macron veut organiser un
référendum au hasard sur l'immigration
ça passera par une révision de la
Constitution oui il faut élargir le
champ de l'article 11 un chiffre un seul
Thomas depuis la création de la
Cinquième République il y a eu 9
référendum au total 8 d'entre eux sont
passés par la voie de cet article 11
mais jamais aucun de référendum n'a
porté sur une question économique ou
sociale si Emmanuel Macron au hasard ou
la droite souhaite que les Français
tranchent sur de nouveaux sujets par
exemple sur le dossier de l'immigration
et bien il va falloir bâtir un lâche
consensus politique surtout si l'on veut
modifier ce fameux article 11 regarde du
contexte politique actuel ça va pas être
très simple évidemment ça va prendre du
temps merci beaucoup merci
inauguré ce nouveau poste de ravi de
chroniqueurs sur le plateau de de sens
public uncharine business me tourne vers
vous parce que effectivement est-ce que
c'est le meilleur moment politique pour
se lancer dans une révision de la
Constitution la réponse est non
évidemment non puisque sur l'équilibre
la révision de la Constitution pour
modifier l'article 11 elle est
techniquement tout à fait réalisable il
vous suffit d'ajouter un petit alinéa
avec certaines politiques que vous voyez
vous voulez voir discuter par le peuple
mais c'est politiquement très difficile
à faire passer notamment parce que il ne
faut pas oublier que le référendum est
quand même une concurrence de la
démocratie représentative et donc vous
devez faire avaler par le Parlement
l'idée que vous allez le contourner dans
plusieurs processus de décision donc
c'est parfois un petit peu difficile à
installer et puis rappelons le concert
le contexte de majorité relative
d'Emmanuel Macron qui lui oblige
finalement lorsqu'on passe par une
révision dite du Congrès c'est-à-dire où
tous les membres des deux assemblées
doivent être présent et bien à aller
chercher de l'accord élargie aux trois
cinquième des membres de ces deux
assemblées donc ça fait beaucoup et
autant dire que la révision de la
Constitution ça n'est pas quelque chose
qui est très facile à faire passer comme
prioritaire alors que l'opinion est
plutôt sensible aux questions de pouvoir
d'achat les à l'international et donc
cette réforme institutionnelle elle peut
paraître un petit peu anachronique
effectivement une pression continue du
parti LR sur le thème de l'immigration
avec ou sans référendum je propose de
d'écouter Gérard Larcher donc toujours
sur France Inter il rappelait qu'un
texte a déjà été travaillé on va dire
par les sénateurs
je reprends l'interview assez longue à
votre confrère le point du du chef
n'est plus tenable et donc quand une
situation n'est plus tenable et bien il
faut la règle et il faut la régler et
nous avons déjà un texte qui a été
déposé mais c'est parce qu'il a dit sur
ça par contre le président Macron vous
l'avez lu aussi dit on va reprendre le
texte que nous nous avons écrit sur un
texte alors vous êtes d'accord ou pas
sur ça de retravailler à partir du texte
gouvernemental et par vos textes
à la commission des lois il a terminé
son examen son premier examen
ce texte travaillé au Sénat il y a aussi
celui qui avait été proposé on s'en
souvient à parler les deux ministres à
la fois Gérald Darmanin et le ministre
du Travail enfin qui incarnait
l'équilibre à gouvernance sauf qu'on se
rend compte que c'est devenu un piège
pour le gouvernement entre son aile
gauche et son aile droite en quelque
sorte est-ce que vous diriez ça oui mais
alors la proposition de référendum sur
l'immigration en fait tient-elle à un
coût politique un coup politique ou à
une volonté sincère et profonde de
tenter de résorber de contribuer à
résorber la crise démocratique c'est ça
le sujet si le si les LR constitué un
parti de gouvernement responsable je
crains qu'il ne fasse pas trop fausse
route en essayant d'instrumentaliser la
question de l'immigration à cette fin il
y a une forme de paradoxe ou même
d'hypocrisie française on a cette espèce
de culture bonapartiste demi du chef et
de lien direct avec le avec le peuple et
en même temps comme le rappeler votre
sujet tout à l'heure même s'il y a eu 9
référendum depuis le début de la
cinquième République le dernier remonte
à quoi 2005 ça va faire quasiment 20 ans
en fait qu'on n'a pas donné la parole au
peuple sous forme de référendum alors
pourtant quand même le contexte a changé
s'il a précisément un comme élément de
diagnostic une crise démocratique très
profonde une crise de défiance le fait
quand même de donner la parole au peuple
de donner la parole aux peuple et de à
intervalle très régulier avoir cette
espèce de purge démocratique devrait
être bien davantage utilisé et au plan
national et encore plus au plan local
mais deuxième dimension s'il y a et la
crise démocratique est par ailleurs une
société archipelisée ou fracturée il
faut aussi choisir des sujets qui nous
permettent de gagner et en cause et en
cohésion et en maturité collective si le
premier sujet qu'on inscrit à l'ordre du
jour c'est le sujet le plus clivant du
moment à savoir l'immigration je pense
que précisément on amplifie les
problèmes au lieu de contribuer à les
résorber votre avis là-dessus parce
qu'elle période est peut-être boucler ce
chapitre référendum ce mot-là
préférendum qui avait été sorti du
chapeau par Olivier Véran un peu je
crois rapidement si l'on en croit les
participants des rencontres de
Saint-Denis les chefs de parties
enterrés par le président République
votre avis sur ces
sérieux et là-dessus faut pas jouer avec
encore une nouvelle initiative dont on
ne voit pas très bien et même
apparemment le président de la
République ne voyait pas très bien les
limites de ce que lui proposait Olivier
mais un préférence plusieurs questions
ou contre le président etc etc la limite
je vais vous dire crûment les sondages
font très bien leur travail s'il s'agit
de faire ça voyez on pourrait proposer
un échantillon présentatif massif de la
population française par le biais du
sondage de de faire ce travail que le
préfère un homme voudrait faire non et
sur le côté clivant d'un
le référendum ça peut être le meilleur
comme le pire des instruments ça peut
dégénérer en effet en plébiscite ou en
contre plébiscite et puis ça peut comme
c'est le cas dans de nombreux pays
européens je pense en particulier à nos
voisins en Suisse être une occasion d'un
débat qui parfois est un débat qui prend
les gens par le haut j'étais quand
j'étais professeur à Genève j'ai assisté
comme ça à plusieurs votations disent
nos voisins suisses et je vous assure
que ça manquait pas d'allure le débat
démocratique en Suisse autour de
certaines votations et souvenons-nous
par exemple en 1992 le référendum sur le
traité de Maastricht ça ne manquait pas
d'allure la qualité du débat à gauche à
droite
souvenons-nous du grand débat entre le
Président de la République François
Mitterrand et Philippe Séguin tout ça ne
manquait pas d'allure et d'ailleurs les
électeurs ont répondu et ont répondu
massivement par le taux d'administration
mais le taux de participation même chose
d'ailleurs en 2005 alors simplement là
le peuple a dit non donc tout le monde
est saisi de tétanie et donc faut pas se
tromper dans le premier sujet que l'on
mettra au référendum un tout dernier
modèle ensuite on reparle de la
communication d'Emmanuel Macron comment
sur l'élargissement du champ du
référendum on nous parle peut-être des
questions sociales du droit civil du
droit pénal ça n'est pas anodin qu'au
moment de 58 ces champs-là étaient
exclus du référendum et c'est pour de
bonnes raisons qui sont notamment celles
justement du caractère clivant et du
caractère dangereux aussi d'avoir dans
le débat public des débats on nous en a
parlé il y a quelques mois seulement à
propos de l'inscription dans la
Constitution du droit à l'IVG où le
gouvernement lui-même a adhéré à la peau
à la position officielle de la PPL qui
consistait à dire on aimerait éviter le
référendum sur cette question parce que
ça va retendre un petit peu l'opinion
donc je crois que avant d'élargir la
liste des questions référendaires il
faut réfléchir à cela est-ce que le
peuple est vraiment prêt à tout voter et
est-ce que c'est une bonne chose d'avoir
un débat sur tout allez à tout dernier
mot on a commencé par les initiatives
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est un peu le fil
rouge de notre débat et bien justement
cette fin d'après midi de lundi il avait
choisi de répondre à nos confrères Hugo
travers sur Tik Tok et Youtube pour
s'adresser à la jeunesse d'ailleurs le
premier thème dont il a parlé c'est la
santé mentale des jeunes à court extrait
plus on a des jeunes qui ne tombent pas
dans des formes aiguës et ne se retrouve
pas dans les urgences psychiatriques
plus on développe des maisons des
adolescents qui permettent justement
pour les jeunes leurs familles qui
commencent à avoir des troupes d'être
accompagnés plus on évite ça mais il n'y
a pas de solution miracle pour avoir
d'un seul coup plusieurs milliers de
psychiatres en plus dans notre pays
parce qu'il faut les former
Mathieu souker c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
cherche à parler aux jeunes c'est pas
nouveau il l'a déjà fait plusieurs fois
d'ailleurs déjà en utilisant certains de
ces de ces réseaux sociaux qu'est-ce qui
on est dans une séquence avec la rentrée
avec c'est cette logique de
communication politique que vous voyez
derrière oui très classiquement mais
d'ailleurs va je trouve qu'il faut un se
réjouir le président cherche à parler
aux jeunes c'est assurément un bon
vecteur c'est une émission de qualité
avec un journaliste un jeune journaliste
de qualité et par ailleurs le sujet
qu'il évoquait à l'instant est en fait
un sujet majeur c'est-à-dire que là pour
le coup toutes les statistiques
clignotent en rouge s'agissant de la
santé de l'état de santé mentale déjà du
pays globalement et des jeunes en
particulier donc précisément alors
malheureusement il répond en disant
qu'on ne sait pas sortir des psychiatres
du chapeau comme ça pourtant été il
faudrait que la France comme d'autres
pays mais la France en particulier lance
un vaste plan en la matière Pascal
Perrino le l'enjeu d'Emmanuel Macron
c'était déjà l'enjeu de sa première
année de second quinquennat mais c'est
toutes les initiatives dont on parle
c'est ça c'est de de pas s'enfermer dans
dans une impasse pour quatre ans quoi
c'est vraiment ce à quoi on assiste là
voilà et c'est un problème qui le menace
c'est pour ça qu'il disait d'ailleurs
vous savez cette remarque qui est un peu
surprise limitée à deux mandats les
mandats présidentiels voilà c'est une
bêtise hein il l'a pas dit une funeste
voilà c'est une grosse bêtise donc ça
veut dire ce que ça veut dire c'est à
dire que quand on est fait on est dans
son deuxième mandat et bien voilà on a
un mal fou à peser et c'est pas
simplement la majorité relative bien sûr
quand on a la majoritaire relative ça
devient encore plus difficile mais ça
devient très compliqué d'exister et là
au fond il a choisi d'exister un peu par
des thèmes qui lui avait été favorable
en 2017 c'est-à-dire l'image de la
jeunesse l'image de
l'éducation etc et c'est ce qu'il remet
à l'agenda au-delà de la com et si on ne
voit s'il y a quelque chose
véritablement d'important qui se met en
place on suivra ça dans les prochaines
heures dans les prochains jours merci à
tous c'est votre rentrée à l'université
aussi à tous les deux là vous préparer
ça pour demain demain voilà tout le
monde fait sa rentrée donc c'est un vrai
plaisir merci encore d'être venu
inauguré ce nouveau décor de j'en suis
vu que c'était un grand plaisir